c'est l'odeur d'un franc succès qui a
flotté hier sur la ville dans les fours
du cyber douane et justice sont
incinérés la perspective de très gros
bénéfices pour les trafiquants européens
1031 kg de cannabis poussait dans la
fosse la fine fleur un produit de luxe
d'autant plus courue sur le marché en
ces périodes de restrictions durant le
confinement les trafiquants au plus
grand mal à se réapprovisionner avec la
fermeture des frontières et donc les le
prix de ces produits ont flambé et donc
il était d'autant plus compliquée pour
les services des douanes les services de
police de gardienne et dans de bonnes
conditions une telle quantité de
stupéfiants ne par son volume plus de 30
mètres cubes de sa valeur entre 20 et 30
millions d'euros à la revente que la
décision était prise effectivement que
j'ai pris cette décision de de détruire
au plus vite ces produits stupéfiants
la saisie s'est faite comme dans 90% des
cas grâce à l'intuition et au sens de
l'observation des hommes de terrain
entre maroc et l'europe de l'est
un camion presque comme un autre que des
agents choisissent de dérouter mais à
l'ouverture des portes banco derrière un
paravent de palettes des cartons à peine
dissimulée l'urgence de la commande
explique sans doute les risques pris par
les trafiquants le commerce se libère et
donc comme d'autres marchandises celle
ci était légale bien entendu comme
d'autres marchandises effectivement il
ya une demande demande forte
donc forcément il y a
une offre une livraison qui doit être
peut-être plus forte puisqu'elle s'est
contenue pendant un certain temps
spectaculaire indice du redémarrage de
l'activité souterraine cette saisie ne
doit pas faire oublier que le camp
adverse s'adapte sans cesse confinement
ou pas on a observé durant cette peine
de confinement de deux phénomènes d'une
part des consommateurs qui faisait
beaucoup moins de déplacements mais qui
achetaient en plus grosse quantité pour
limiter leurs déplacements à éviter
d'être contrôlé et puis également des
trafiquants qui était qui avait organisé
un système de revente à domicile dans le
même temps les autorités sanitaires ont
noté une augmentation des prescriptions
de produits de substitution signe d'une
volonté de sevrage de toxicomanes lourd
un effet positif inattendue du
confinement